nachricht aus wird heute die inzidenz
auf der luxus insel liegt bei über
1.500 gastronomische betriebe schließen
freiwillig und gleichzeitig diese bilder
aus garmisch es sind bilder vom samstag
mitten im skigebiet am hausberg hunderte
menschen stehen dicht gedrängt am
skilift an abstand fehlanzeige
stattdessen menschenmengen auf engstem
raum omikron welches omikron aber nur
gut 100 kilometer nördlich wiederum nur
einen tag zuvor
da sehen wir nämlich die allianz arena
in münchen
rückrundenauftakt in der bundesliga
bayern münchen gegen borussia
mönchengladbach vor leeren rängen keine
zuschauer in der liga erlaubt wie passt
das zusammen wer soll das noch verstehen
jan fleischhauer jedenfalls nicht
kolumnist ehemals beim spiegel jetzt
beim fokus auf twitter hat er mit
folgender aussage ja den nerv der
menschen tatsächlich getroffen ich habe
zwei jahre alles mitgemacht ich bin
geimpft und gebuchter von mir aus kann
die nächste welle nicht nur eine wand
sondern ein gebirgsmassiv sein ich bin
raus ich werde mein leben nicht mehr an
modellen ausrichten die das schlimmste
annehmen
passend dazu der trendige hashtag ich
bin raus und jetzt ist er uns
zugeschaltet guten tag herr fleischhauer
herr fleischhauer warum sind sie raus
also ich bin heilig abend mit der
familie nach lanzarote geflogen entgegen
allen empfehlung der bundesregierung die
ja empfohlen hatte also auf alle
unnötigen reisen verzichten und sich am
weihnachtsfest nur mit leuten treffen im
engsten familienkreis nach vorlage des
ausweises und ich dachte er gar nicht
dass überfluss und unbeschwertes leben
möglich ist es war die beste
entscheidung die letzten monate und dann
habe ich gedacht also ja ich bin geimpft
ich bin gewusst hat ich habe alles
mitgemacht
also entweder glaubt man jetzt mal an
den effekt der impfung dass wir uns also
schwere verläufe erspart
oder wir sind ohnehin alle verloren und
da habe ich mich doch für das erst
entschieden aber sie haben gerade selber
gesagt sie haben eigentlich monate lang
mitgemacht woher plötzlich dieser
sinneswandel ist kann er nicht nur ein
urlaub auf lanzarote gewesen sein
das heißt alles mitgemacht als ich mich
halt mich nach wie vor hier auch einen
regeln also ich würde jetzt nicht da
hingehen und mein kind also ist der
hochrisiko gebiet spanien ja gleich am
nächsten tag in die schule schicken und
verheimlichen dass euch auf lanzarote
war aber sagen wir dieses hinschauen auf
die zahlen auf die allerschlimmsten
annahmen da kommt dann immer ja
irgendwann wurde liga um die ecke und
sagt also mitte januar werden sich zehn
millionen infiziert haben und dann kommt
der nächste und sagt 40 millionen werden
sein und
aus dem spiel bewegung heraus also ich
habe beschlossen also die n tv app mit
dem corona live ticker die wir jetzt
erstmal abgeschaltet und ich werde auch
nicht mehr also nur noch ein halber höhe
hinhören wenn karl lauterbach und
erobert mit herr wieder auftauchen und
das ist ja das interessante deswegen
haben sie es ja auch jetzt auch heute in
ihrer sendung das ist ja das ist ganz
ganz vielen leuten offenbar nerv
getroffen die aussage ich habe mich
vernünftig verhalten ich trage mal der
maske davos angesagt ist ich habe meine
impfung mehr abgeholt
aber ich bin jetzt ich bin jetzt aus dem
panik modus gibt es noch eine chance sie
zurückzugewinnen was müssten das rkw und
die krone experten tun
es zurückgewinnen sie meinen dass ich
mich wieder zu hause ein schließt ja und
und sagt nee also omikron jetzt wird
mich in front doch erwischen er wird es
ja nur das ganz gute was man ja auch
sehen kann ja da baut sich die welle
auch von der jetzt alle sagen das ist
die wand aber es hat sich also ein
bisschen entkoppelt zum glück von den
schweren verläufen und
ich halte das für ein leben also es wird
ja immer irgendein variante geben das
ist das ist schon mal klar also wenn
jetzt oregon vorbei ist kommt die
nächste variante der vermutlich noch
leichter zu übertragen ist und
potenziellen ob wir noch gefährlicher
also wollen wir jetzt über die nächsten
zehn jahre jedes mal beim weihnachts ist
ja den kreis der lieben auf auf drei der
vier leute
begrenzen und bei jemanden der den
impfnachweis vergessen hat ihn entweder
rausschicken oder sage nochmal es muss
zugleich vom gartenzaun auszugucken dass
das kann das leben sein aber fleischer
was heißt dann ich bin raus sie sagen ja
dass sie sich andererseits weiterhin an
die regeln halten wollen und müssen
natürlich auch die sorge haben dass das
was sie hier machen eine sozusagen
wasser auf die mühlen der querdenker ist
vielleicht noch eine kurze antwort dazu
gut es gibt immer leute die
sachen so verstehen wollen wie sie sie
verstehen dann wollen und klar also ich
bin raus heißt jetzt nicht ab morgen
halte ich als willig gesetzesbrecher
oder laub vor irgendwelchen querträger
dancers aus aber es gibt ja es gibt ja
was dazwischen
also klar weiterhin maske tragen wenn
man in der öffentlichkeit unterwegs ist
aber zum beispiel
kein schlechtes gewissen haben wenn man
urlaub fliegt also wird sie mit denen
wenn sie mit den ganz harten lockdown
befürwortern reden und das war ja wie
gesagt die empfehlung der
bundesregierung
dann sollten wir eigentlich über die
nächsten wochen und monate auf urlaube
und längere reisen verzichten da sollte
mal lieber mit
danke
er und auch die debatte um eine
impfpflicht die lässt nicht nach die
frage ob solch eine pflicht kommt wurde
gestern abend auch bei die richtigen
fragen diskutiert besonders linken
politikerin sahra wagenknecht hat dazu
eine ganz klare meinung ich finde wir
sollten als politiker doch versuchen
ehrlich zu sein also den menschen
wirklich die wahrheit zu sagen ihnen
nicht etwas vorzugaukeln und die
impfpflicht debatte lebt von einem
vorgaukeln nämlich wir haben da ein
super instrument damit kommen wir aus
der pandemie nein die impfung hat ihre
wichtige bedeutung für ältere dass sie
eine gewisse zeit vor schweren verläufen
schützt das ist richtig und ist wichtig
und ich werde auch dafür dass sich
ältere impfen lassen aber wir haben
nicht das zaubermittel und die
impfpflicht ist ein solcher eingriff in
die persönliche integrität und und
dieses persönliche sozusagen die
gesundheit eines menschen
da darf der staat nicht in solcher form
über gerückt werden bei dem
kenntnisstand den wir zurzeit haben also
starker tobak die impfpflicht debatte
lebt von einem
vorgaukeln die aussage der linken
politikerin sahra wagenknecht bei uns
das bild politik redakteur sebastian
geisler also etwas an wie beurteilst du
diese aussage also in einem punkt stimme
ich eher zu ich finde vorgaukeln klingt
so als wenn man jetzt da irgendwie
getäuscht worden aber es ist ja immer
gesagt worden dass impfen ist der weg
raus aus der pandemie das habe auch ich
hier schon mal gesagt das haben wir ja
tatsächlich auch angenommen dass man mit
vollständigen impfschutz dann
tatsächlich geschützt ist jetzt wissen
wir dass impfen schützt und zwar
insbesondere vor schweren verläufen aber
es ist eben nicht der weg tatsächlich
raus aus der pandemie sondern wir können
nur hoffen dass es mit omikron jetzt
möglicherweise besser wird ich habe es
auch in meiner corona abgesehen da steht
jetzt zum beispiel auch nur noch nicht
mehr vollständiger impfschutz sondern
sie haben alle derzeit geplanten
impfungen erhalten das heißt wir müssen
damit rechnen dass weitere booster
impfung vielleicht nötig sind sebastian
du hast das interview mit jan
fleischhauer mitverfolgt kannst du
verstehen dass er sagt und auch viele
menschen ich bin raus ich möchte mich
nicht mehr von den maßnahmen
beeinflussen lassen ehrlich gesagt schon
er sagt jetzt ja auch gar nicht will
jetzt sich da nichts mehr halten davon
würde ich auch dringend abraten sagte
man muss weiterhin maske tragen alles
wirklich richtig aber er sagt diese
horrorszenarien von denen will er sich
nicht mehr so zu sagen das leben
vermiesen lassen und er hat ja auch
nicht das ist ja auch rational zu sagen
wenn vielleicht demnächst eine neue
variante kommt die vielleicht auch mal
wieder schlimmer sein kann ist es ja
sinnvoll wenn ich sage dann bin ich
jetzt wenigstens auch im urlaub gewesen
habe mich zwar geschützt habe zum
beispiel im flugzeug konsequent maske
getragen das ist ja sinnvoll es ist
nicht gut immer nur auf diese
horrorzahlen und horrorszenarien zu
gucken und sein leben nur noch nach
seinem corona kult auszurichten sich
selbst schützen und vernünftig sein
alles alles in ordnung alles gut aber
ich würde mich da ich kann mich da
durchaus wieder erkennen in dem was er
hier sagt nämlich wir sollten nicht
unser leben nur noch von angst bestimmen
lassen sondern wir müssen auch lernen
mit dem virus tatsächlich zu leben ich
glaube das können wir alle gut
nachvollziehen coroner müde sind wir auf
jeden fall vielen dank sebastian geisler
für eine einschätzung